اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
العاجله والمباشره والحيه للنزاع المسلح
في السودان وهذا النزاع المستمر منذ تسعه
ايام الصراع يدخل اسبوعه الثاني لا بوادر
للتهدئه هذا اليوم التاسع من الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع تتزايد
معه ارقام الضحايا والمصابين وفي اخر
الاحصائيات نشر مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه
بالامم المتحده تقريرا يعرض فيه اعداد
القتلى والمصابين في اشتباكات السوداني
وتبعاتها حيث رصد مقتل
412 شخصا واصابه
3500 اخرين في الاشتباكات بالسودان حتى
الجمعه الماضيه العاصمه الخرطوم مشاهدينا
تصدرت المدن في اعداد القتلى
ب132 تليها ولايه شمال كردوفان بخمسه
وتسعين قتيلا وشمال دارفوربي 61 قتيلا
التقرير ايضا الى زياده عمليات النزوح من
جميع مناطق الخرطوم ومدينه الابيض بشمال
كردفان بسبب استمرار الاشتباكات ولجوء نحو
20 الف سوداني الى تشاد الذين يعانون الان
من ظروف انسانيه صعبه التقرير حذر ايضا من
الافتقار لمياه الشرب الذي قد يؤدي الى
زياده خطر الاصابه بالامراض بما في ذلك
اذا وعلى صعيد عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن بدء
عمليه اجراء سريعه لمواطنيها ولطاقمها
الدبلوماسي من السودان بعد ان دخلت
المعارك العنيفه اسبوعها الثاني ولفتاه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى ان العمليه ستشمل
ايضا مواطنين اوروبيين واخرين منحدرين من
دول شريكه حليفه وانها حصلت على ضمانات من
طرفي الصراع في السودان لتامين عمليه
الاجلاء
وفي بيان قبل قليل الجيش السوداني اتهم
فيها قوات الدعم السريع بارتكابي عدد من
الانتهاكات على بعثات دبلوماسيه منها
الاعتداء على موكب السفاره الفرنسيه
باطلاق النار ما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل
عمليه الاجلاء بالاضافه الى اصابه احد
الفرنسيين بعيار الناري من قناص بالاضافه
الى مهاجمه مقر البعثه في بر وفقا للبيان
الصادر عن مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات
المسلحه الذي اشار ايضا الى قيام الدعم
السريع بالاعتداء على موكب اخلاء افراد
السفاره القطريه المتجهه الى بورتسودان
وقامت بنهب اموالهم وجميع حقائبهم
وهواتفهم النقاله
قال السفير الروسي في السودان انتريه
الدبلوماسيين الروس في السودان يدرسون
جميع الطرق الممكنه لاجلاء المواطنين
وتنفيذ عمليه اجلاء جويه في حال تحسنت
الاوضاع في المطار واشار ايضا الى ان
مغادره الرعايه الروس الى بوتسودان ممكنه
من الناحيه النظريه لكنها مرتبطه بصعوبات
اللوجستيه كبيره تتعلق بالنقل والامن كما
اشار السفير الروسي الى ان الطرفي الصراع
في السودان مستعدان لمساعده في اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب لكن هناك صعوبات موضوعيه
حول او تحول دون تحقيق ذلك
اقامه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعمليه
اجراء نوعيه لرعاياها من مقر السفاره
الامريكيه في ضاحيه سوبا جنوب الخرطوم
وذلك بمشاركه ست طائرات الامريكيه هبطت في
مبنى السفاره وكانت قياده الدعم السريع
السودانيه اصدرت بيانا اوضحت فيه ان
قواتها نسقت مع القوات الامريكيه المكونه
من ست طائرات بغرض اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
واسرهم وان قوه الدعم السريع قامت
بالاشراف على الترتيبات اللازمه التي سبقت
عمليه الاجلاء
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بدوره اكد ان
عمليه الاجلاء التي قال الجيش التي قال ان
الجيش الامريكي فذهب باوامر منه قال ان
الجيش نجح في اجراء الامريكيين الى بر
الامان متوجها بالشكر للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجيبوتي واثيوبيا حيث وصف بايدن
دور هذه الدول بالحاسمه في نجاح عمليه
الاجلاء ودعى الرئيس الامريكي الاطراف
المتحاربه لتنفيذ وقف فوري وغير مشروط
لاطلاق النار والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق واحترام ايرادات
الشعب السوداني
ان بلاده علقت بصفه مؤقته العمليات في
سفاراتها بالخرطوم بسبب تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه واجلت جميع الموظفين الامريكيين
وعائلاتهم بامان واضاف بلنكن ان الاداره
الامريكيه ستواصل مساعده الامريكيين في
السودان في التخطيط لسلامتهم مكررا الدعوه
لطرفي الصراع بتمديد هدنه العيد وتوسيع
نطاقها على نحو عاجل من اجل وقف دائم
للاعمال القتاليه
معسكر
رسميا هو القاعده العسكريه الدائمه
والوحيده التي تديرها القوات الامريكيه في
افريقيا
جغرافيا هي اقرب قاعده امريكيه في المنطقه
للاحداث في السودان وهي تقع في دوله
جيبوتي
القاعده تضم وحدات من القوات الخاصه
والبحريه والطيران ويصل عدد القوات فيها
الى اربعه الاف جندي في الاوقات العاديه
تستغل لحمايه الملاحه البحريه في باب
المندب وفي استهداف الجماعات الارهابيه في
القرن الافريقي اضافه الى تدريب الجنود
التابعين لدول افريقيه مختلفه
معسكر ليموني يحتوي على مطار عسكري قد
يكون هو المحور الاساسي في اي عمليه اخلاء
محتمله للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
انس النماسي العربيه
ومعنى من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه في
باريس حسين قنابل حسين مرحبا بك معي في
هذه
التغطيه للاحداث في السودان قبل قليل ربما
تابعتها وتابع الفرنسيون ايضا كذلك بيان
الجيش والذي تحدث عن مهاجمه البعثه
الفرنسيه التي كانت متوجهه الى يعني ربما
بورتسودان لاجلاء بعثتها من هناك لكن قوات
الدعم السريع كما اتهمها الجيش هاجمت هذه
البعثه الفرنسيه هل العلاقه الفرنسيون
اولا على هذه الانباء او هناك معلومات
توفرت حتى اللحظه حسين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الواقع ما ورد من مصادر السودانيه بشان
هذا الحادث لم تعلق عليه فرنسا رسميا بعد
اقله حتى الان ما صدر عن وزاره الخارجيه
قبل حوالي ساعه والنصف الساعه من الان
ركز على ان الوزاره ستبدا بالاشتراك
بالتنسيق مع وزاره الدفاع ايضا
بعمليه اجلاء سريعه
لرعايه فرنسا وطواقم بعثاتها دبلوماسيه في
السودان وذلك بالتنسيق مع كل الاطراف
المعنيه ومع شركاء الاوروبيين والحلفاء
تشمل عمليه الاجلاء مواطنين من دول شريكه
وحليفه ايضا اضاف البيان الفرنسي ان طرفي
النزاع في السودان وهما الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع قدم ضمانات امنيه تسمح
بعمليات الاجلاء عدد الفرنسيين المقيمين
في السودان يبلغ حوالى
250 شخصا نايف هل تحدثوا عن من سيؤمن هذه
العمليه حسين
في الواقع الاستعدادات للشروع بهذه
العمليه كانت بدات قبل ايام عندما ارسلت
فرنسا طائرات الى جيبوتي حيث توجد كما
تعلم قاعده عسكريه بعد ارسال هذه الطائرات
الاربعاء الماضي بدا الحديث عن ان سلاح
البر في الجيش الفرنسي مستنفر ايضا تمهيدا
للشروع في عمليه الاجلاء حتى الان ليس
معروفا ما اذا كانت العمليه عمليه الاجلاء
ستجري جوا وهذا مستبعد لان الظروف الامنيه
المحيطه بالمطار غير متوفره كما ان مطار
الخرطوم مغلق كما تعلم وكذلك المجال الجوي
وهذا ما يرجح فرضيه ان تحصل عمليه الاجلاء
برا كانت فرنسا تحدثت عن انه هو قبل البدء
بعمليه الاجلاء يجب ان تتوفر سلسله شروط
وظروف بينها او الضمان امن المجال الجوي
وضمان امن المطار وكذلك التامين وصول من
يراد اجلائهم الى نقاط محدده مسبقا هذه
الظروف ليست متوفره كلها لاجلاء هؤلاء
الرعايه جوا وبالتالي فانه على الارجح ان
يصار الى اجلائهم برا ولكن اضاحات فرنسيه
ستصدر لاحقا بهذا الشان
الخارجيه الفرنسيه كانت قد قالت بان هناك
ضمانات من طرفي الصراع لسلامه عمليه
الاجلاء من السودان حسين لكن الان هل نحن
امام سيناريو اجلاء هذه البعثه الفرنسيه
وكذلك ايضا رعايه بعض الدول الشركه
والحليفه ايضا كما وصفات الخارجيه
الفرنسيه عبر البر الى جيبوتي ومن هناك
الى القاعده
العسكريه الفرنسيه ومن ثم الى باريس ام
ستكون برا الى البحر الى بورتسودانت
تحديدا ومن هناك يعني تنطلق هذه البعثه
عبر البحر حسين ان كان هناك من سيناريو
مرجح
لا يعطي الفرنسي الفرنسيون اي تفاصيل بشان
الكيفيه والامكنه التي
سيصار الى اعتمادها خلال عمليه الاجلاء
بعض الاسباب يعودوا بعض ذلك يعود الى
اسباب امنيه نايف ولكن تعرف ان فرنسا قامت
بعمليات اجلاء خلال السنوات والعقود
الماضيه حصل ذلك في لبنان في اليمن وفي
دول افريقيه من بينها موريتانيا ساحل
العاج والكونغو اخر عمليه اجلاء كانت من
كابول حيث اجلى الجيش الفرنسي بين الخامس
عشر والثامن والعشرين من اب اغسطس من
العام الماضي
2800 شخص عبر 26 رحله جويه بين كابول وابو
ظبي ثم سته عشره رحله بين ابوظبي والتاريخ
اذا لفرنسا لجيشها تحديدا تجربه طويله مع
عمليات الاجلاء من مناطق خطيره في العالم
نايف
الشكر حسين على كل هذه المعلومات المتوفره
ايضا لديك عام طبعا شح المعلومات طبعا
فيما يخص البعثه الفرنسيه التي سيتم
اجلاؤها من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك مدير
مكتب قناه العربيه في باريس حسين غنيبر
الحياه
الاجلاء الامريكيه مشاهدينا سبقتها عمليه
اجلاء سعوديه حيث قالت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ان مواطني المملكه الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان وصلوا الى البلاد
بالاضافه الى عدد من رعايا الدول الاخرى
وبينت الوزاره في بيان ان القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه اجلت واحد وتسعين سعوديا
ونحو 66 شخصا من عشر دول اخرى عربيه
واجنبيه واكدت الخارجيه ان المملكه عملت
على توفير كامل الاحتياجات الاساسيه
للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم
الى بلدانهم
من جانبه قال نائب وزير الخارجيه السعودي
وليد الخريجي ان معظم السعوديين الذين
طلبوا الاجلاء من السودان تم اجلائهم
وخلال استقباله السعوديين والرعايه
الاجانب العائدين من السودان الى جده اوضح
نائبه وزير الخارجيه السعودي ان هناك
تكاتفا بين كافه الاجهزه لتنفيذ عمليه
الاجلاء مؤكدا ان وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
لعبت دورا كبيرا في تنفيذها واضاف ان لدى
وزاره الخارجيه توجيهات للعمل على راحه
السعوديين في الخارج
نتواجد على متن سفينه جلاله الملك ابها
وهي اخر سفن الخاصه الاول التي خصصت
لعمليات الاجلاء من السودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده على متنها 37 شخص
جنسيات متعدده بمقدمتها الجنسيه
الاماراتيه والقطريه وكذلك الجنسيه
البنغلاديشيه وغيرها من الجنسيات العربيه
وغير العربيه نتحدث عن 37 شخص وهي الدفعه
الاخيره من 158 شخص تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
برا الى بورت سودان ومن ثم بحرا الى مدينه
جده وتحديدا في قاعده الملكه فيصل البحريه
هنا في جده نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء تمت
بعمليات بكل يسر وسهوله من خلال تنسيق
عالي بين قطاعات حكوميه عده وبين السفاره
السعوديه وقوات البحريه السعوديه وكذلك
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه نتحدث عن واحد
وتسعين السعودي من ضمن المائه 158 شخص تم
اجلاهم اكثر من 11 جنسيه في اعمار مختلفه
مخصصه القوات البحريه خمسه سفن اربعه منها
هي خاصه بعمليات الاجلاء والخامسه كانت هي
خاصه بعمليات التموين جميعها وصلت منذ
ساعات مبكره وهذه هي السفينه الاخيره وهي
السفينه جلاله الملك
ابها وهي السفينه الاخيره الخاصه بعمليه
النقل او اجلاء الرعايه نتحدث انه 158 شخص
وصلوا جميعهم الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ونتواجد الان
على متن السفينه الاخيره الخاصه بعمليات
الاجلاء نتحدث انه وصلت تباعا بينهما ما
يقارب الخمسه واربعين دقيقه عمليه نقل تمت
وفق تنظيم ووفق تنسيقات عاليه بين الحكومه
السعوديه وعدد من الجهات هنالك في الخرطوم
للتاكد من وصول وسلامه كافه الرعايه من
السعوديين وغير السعوديين
عمليه تنظيم الاجلاء من الخرطوم كانت تسير
بشكل ممتاز رغم ان الرحله كانت مخيفه بعض
الشيء كنا خائفين جدا مما كان يجري هناك
بسبب المعارك لكن السفاره السعوديه اتت
الينا الى منازلنا لانقاذنا وذهبنا في
موكب الى بورت سودان ثم الى هنا بواسطه
السفن السعوديه لم تكن لدينا خطه للاجلاء
كنا نترقب فقط لكن السفاره السعوديه هي
التي ساعدتنا على المغادره كنت على متن
الخطوط السعوديه او من الناس اللي كنا
ركاب الطياره والحمد لله طلعنا بسلام
طيبين وبخير وتم اجلائنا اول شيء وصلنا
للسفاره السعوديه ثم خرجنا من السفاره
السعوديه على اجراء
كان سلس وسهل الحمد لله
ونشكر خدمه الشريفين وولي عهده الامين
ووزير الخارجيه وكل القائمين على هذا
الاجلاء الناجح
ومن القاهره تنضم الى صحه في المختصه في
الشان الافريقي صباح موسى مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه قبل قليل
الخارجيه المصريه قالت بان هناك اصابه
لاحد افراد
او اعضاء السفاره في الخرطوم الى ماذا
يؤشر هذا الامر كيف ستتعامل معه القاهره
بالتاكيد الخارجيه اخرجت بيانا تحدثت فيه
في البدايه على انه كيفيه اجلاء الرعايه
المصريين من السودان دعني اشير هنا في عبر
قناتكم بان الخارجيه المصريه تحدثت الى
راعيها الموجودين خارج العاصمه الخرطوم
بالولايات بان يتوجهوا الى نقطتين للحركه
للتحرك الى مصر هي القنصليه المصريه في
بورسودان وايضا مكتب القنصليه بو وادي
حلفا اما بشان الرعايه في الخرطوم هي يعني
نبهتهم بتوخي الحذر والالتزام بمنازلهم
حتى يعني تتاكد السفاره المصريه بتامين
مسارتهم للخروج خارج العاصمه ومن ثم
الحدود الشماليه مع مصر وبالتالي عودتهم
بسلام الى ارض الوطن اما بخصوص الطلق
الناري ايضا البيان تطرق الى
انه احد اعضاء السفاره لطلق الناري وان
مصر يعني يعني هي تعي الامور في السودان
وخطورتها ولذلك
طالبت الجميع بتوخي الحذر فسرت مصر ان مصر
لا تجلي اعضاء بعثتها بعثتها الدبلوماسيه
وهذه يعني عقيده دبلوماسيه راسقه بانها لا
تبلي رعاياها الدبلوماسيين الا اذا تاكدت
اولا انها اجلت كل يعني جاليتها من
المواطنين العاديين الاول فرض السفاره
الدبلوماسي لابد ان يتاكد بان كل الجاليه
المصريه التي ترغب في العوده الى ارض
الوطن قد عادت بامان وان اجلاء الرعايه
الدبلوماسيين يتم بعد ذلك وان هذه عقيده
دبلوماسيه راسقه وبالتالي عمليه الطلق
الناري اعتقد ان مصر تتفهم ان الامور في
السودان يعني امور غير معلومه اعتقد انها
الى يعني هذا النبا واصابه احد اعضاء
سافرتها في الخرطوم دعت اعاياها خارج
الخرطوم الى التوجه لمدينتي حلفا
وبورتسودان ايضا كذلك لاجلائهم هذا يعني
انه لازال هناك مواطنين مصريين موجودين
داخل السودان سيده الصباح
بالتاكيد عمليه اجلاء الرعايه يعني كانت
في البدايه يعني
المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي يتوكل حذر ينتظر
هل هذا الصراع سيتوقف ام ستبتهج ستتجه
الدول الخارجيه لاجلاء رعاياها وبالفعل
بعد مرور تسعه ايام تاكد للمجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي ان الاوضاع تنزلق الى مربع اخطر
وبالتالي قامت الولايات المتحده وبعدها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وغدا فرنسا مصر
تنسق يعني منذ الايام الاولى مع يعني
الجاليه المصريه ورعاياها في السودان وفي
في رباعي السودان وفي العاصمه ولذلك اقرت
هاتين النقطتين التي اشرت اليهما في
القنصليه المصريه ببورسودان وفي مكتب
القنصلي بوادي حلفا هذين النقطتين للرعايه
الموجودين خارج العاصمه
ووضع التليفونات
التواصل مع هاتين النقطتين حتى تتمكن من
عودتهم الى ارض الوطن اما بخصوص من
يتواجدون المصريين المتواجدون في الخرطوم
يعني
طلبتهم بتوخي الحذر والجلوس في منازلهم
حتى تتاكد من مسارات امنه لنقلهم من خارج
العاصمه الخرطوم الى خارج البلاد ايضا
اكدت انه ان القاهره لن تنقل اي دبلوماسي
مصري الا اذا تاكدت انها نقلت كل رعاياها
من المواطنين العاديين ايضا كذلك
اسال عن من سيؤمن هذه العمليه عمليه اجلاء
الجاليه المصريه او ربما ايضا حتى بعد ذلك
اعضاء
البعثه الدبلوماسيه والطاقم الدبلوماسي
الموجود في الخرطوم بالنسبه
للقاهره يعني هل الخيار سيكون للجيش
لتامين هذه العمليه ام للدعم السريع ام
بالتنسيق معهما
يعني شوف اتاكد اتاكد ان اي دوله تريد ان
تؤمن رعاياها ويعني رغم الحديث المنافي
لذلك من الدعم السريع انه يؤمن الرعايه
الاجانب في الخرطوم كذبته حتى الخارجيه
الامريكيه قالت هي فقط اخطرت الطرفين
بانها ستكون هناك طائرات امريكيه في
الاجواء السودانيه حتى لا يكون هناك يعني
الضرب نار او اطلاق عليها ولكن التنسيق
الكامل سيكون مع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
واعتقد ان التامين والتنسيق سيكون مع
القوات المسلحه هذا حدث جليا في موضوع
اجلاء الرعايه او الضباط والعساكر
المصريين كانت التنسيق مع القوات المسلحه
من قبل كان مستشار الدعم السريع على
قناتكم في الفتره السابقه وتحدث عن ان
الضباط والعساكر سلمتهم وامنتهم اه
يعني قوات الدعم السريع وانا يعني اتحدث
هنا بان صحيح انها لم تتعرض لهم بمكروه
ولكنها يعني يعني تتاكد تماما ان مصر لم
تسمح بذلك لو تعرضت اليهم وكانت حريصه جدا
على عودتهم للخرطوم ولكن السؤال هل هي
سلمتهم للقاهره بمحض ارادتها ام ان
القاهره اجبرتها على ذلك وعليهم ان يردوا
على هذا السؤال طيب اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
المشاركه معي من القاهره الصحفيه المختصه
في الشان الافريقي صباح موسى شكرا جزيلا
لك
مع الناس والحقيقه لقينا جامعه كبير جدا
من اولادنا واخواننا في الشارع عدد كبير
جدا وسالناهم قالوا هم قالوا الحمد لله
التقينا اخونا منه علي محمد جمعه اخواني
مرحب بك يا علي طيب انتم العدد كبير جدا
لا تخوف
ورينا الحاصل شنو يا علي
الان والنازل كانوا جوعانين ما في اكل يا
اخي ما في اي حاجه داخل الصين ما فاكر
يعني
السلام عليكم
يا سلام يا سلام
يا سلام كويس في الصراحه الاولى
الصراع
ة
المشاهدين في هذه الاخبار العاجله اسفل
الشاشه قوات الدعم السريع تقول ان الطيران
الجيش هو من استهدف البعثه وموكب اجلاء
الرعايه الفرنسيين وقالت بانها تجدد
الالتزام الكامل بالهدنه وتسهيل حركه
الرعايه الاجانب اذا هذا هو الرد الاولي
من قوات الدعم السريع على بيان الجيش
السوداني الذي اتهم بشكل صريح قوات الدعم
السريع بانها هاجمت البعثات الدبلوماسيه
تحديدا الموكب الفرنسي وكذلك ايضا الموكب
السفاره القطريه
وايضا حتى المصريه التي اصيب احد افراد
هذه السفاره بطلقه الناريه كما ذكرت
خارجيته مصر نعيد التذكير مشاهدينا
بالتصريحات التي ادلى بها رئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان للعربيه والتي اكد فيها ان كل
مطارات السودان تحت سياده الجيش السوداني
باستثناء مطري الخرطوم ونيال واتهم
البرهان قوات الدعم السريع بتفتيش الم
ومصادره الاموال والاعتداء على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه مشيرا الى ان هذه القوه تنتشر
في الاحياء السكنيه والمجمعات الخدميه
اعلى مطار الخرطوم في اشكاليه ومقار نياله
في اشكاليه بقيه بطارات السودان كلها تحت
سيطره الدوله طبعا رعايه الدول اصابهم
الحلع واصابهم الخوف من الممارسات مجموعات
الدعم السريعه داخل سكنيه وهي تفتش
المنازل وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على امتداد
الدبلوماسيه دون
اي
حرمه المواطنين
منتشره داخل احياء السكنيه داخل المجمعات
الخدميه وتقوم
بافعال خلطه الخلق والهلع والروح
وفي الجانب الاخر كشف محمد حمدان دقلو
قائد قوات الدعم السريع في تصريحاته
للعربيه انه متواجد في الخرطوم برفقه
مقاتله حيث يحرص على توجيههم في المعارك
وتتبع تطورات الاشتباكات
لكن هو موجود
في موضوع ثاني
[تصفيق]
المتقاتلين في السودان يثير تساؤلات كثيره
رغم الانباء الوارده من الجانبين فلا دليل
قاطعا على مكان البرهان ولا تاكيد مطلقا
لمكان حميدتي رفيقه دربي بالامس وعدوها
اليوم لم يظهر ميدانيا منذ بدايه المعارك
في ساحه القتال
المعلومات الصادره عن اعلام الطرفين بحسب
الشرق الاوسط تشير الى وجود القاده
العسكريين للقوتين في المقر الرئيسي
للقياده العامه للجيش وسط العاصمه اي في
المحيط ذاته قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد
انه يتولى مهامه ولن يبرح مكانه قائلا انه
يدافع عن السودان
انا موجود في هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي لن اخرج الا محمولا على نعش قبل ذلك
البرهان ظهر في اليوم الثاني من
الاشتباكات في مقطع فيديو لمده ثوان قليله
داخل غرفه الى جانبه قاده عسكريون اما
ظهوره الثاني فكان يوم العيد في خطاب مسجل
صوت وصوره توجه فيه بالتهنئه للشعب
السوداني
الترجيحات تقول ان الغرفه قد تكون ملجا
مخصصا للعمليات السريه في احدى الوحدات
العسكريه التابعه للجيش في مقر القياده
العامه او اي منطقه عسكريه في العاصمه او
خارجها
اما قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
فمنذ بدء العمليات العسكريه لم يظهر على
الاطلاق غير انه اكد في مقابله عبر الهاتف
مع العربيه انه يقود المعارك العسكريه مع
قواته على الارض بنفسه
مراقبون يرون ان قاده الدعم السريع
يتخوفون من سيطره قاده الجيش على اجهزه
الاتصالات وان ظهورهم او اتصالاتهم عبر
الشبكات تسهل تحديد اماكن وجودهم
فكيف ستنتهي قصه الزعيم ونائبه في بلد بدا
يتحول معماره الى عصف ماكول جراء دراوه
المعارك بلال البجدين العربيه
من هما كارتي واسامه عبد الله اللذين او
اللذان ذكرهما الفريق حميتي في مقابله
العربيه نتعرف عليهما
علي احمد كرتي
من مواليد ولايه نهر النيل عام 1953
تخرج من كليه القانون بجامعه الخرطوم عام
من مؤسسي قوات الدفاع الشعبي احد الاذرع
العسكريه لجماعه الاخوان
عين وزير دوله بوزاره العدل
ثم اصبح وزيرا للخارجيه اتهم برئاسه لجنه
لتجنيد ضباط الجيش في صفوف الاخوان لكنه
نفى ذلك
اصدرت انيابه العامه امر اعتقاله بتهمه
التدبير لانقلاب 1989
استردت منه لجنه ازاله التمكين عددا من
القطع السكنيه في مناطق راقيه بالعاصمه
يشغل حاليا منصب الامين العام للحركه
الاسلاميه
اسامه عبد الله احد نزلاء سجن كوبر لضلوعه
في الانقلاب العسكري عام 1989
تم اعتقاله عقب فشل انقلاب الرئيس الاركان
السابق هاشم عبد المطلب
كان مديرا للامن الشعبي الجهاز السري
للحركه الاسلاميه
تولى منصب وزير الكهرباء في الحكومه
السابقه
لاحقه عده تهم فساد لا سيما سد مروي
اتهمته دوائر سودانيه بتحويل وحده تنفيذ
السدود الى اكبر بؤره تمكين لعناصر الحركه
الاسلاميه السياسيه
في يناير 2020 حاول الهروب الى تركيا
الكاتب الصحفي خالد داليا عيسى السيد خالد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه يعني ربما
تابعت قبل قليل بيان الجيش السوداني الذي
تهم فيه قوات الدعم السريع بانها تهاجم
البعثات الدبلوماسيه تحديدا
الموكب الفرنسي وايضا حتى الموكب القطري
وكذلك اصابه احد اعضاء السفر المصريه قوات
الدعم السريع تتهم الجيش بانه هو من نفذ
هذه العمليه عبر الطيرانه الا يفتح هذا
الباب لربما عمليات ستكون خلال عمليات
الاجلاء لا يعرف مصدرها ستكون مصدر
اتهامات بين الطرفين والسودان هو الضحيه
لمشاهدكم الكرام
انا في تقديري ان مؤسسه الجيش هي مؤسسه
محترمه للغايه بالتاكيد منذ
سنوات طويله نتابع مسيره الجيش ولكن هذه
التجربه حرب المدن ربما تكون تجربه حديثه
اذا استطاع الجيش السوداني في حسم كل
المعارك خارج العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
واستطاع ان يسيطر على كل مغار الدعم
السريع في سهوله مصر ولم تعدوا تلك
المعارك سوى ساعات محدوده واستطاع الجيش
ان يفرض فيها السلطان وفي كل الولايات
الان 17 ولايه ولم يستخدم اي اساليب غير
يعني
لم اسال انا عن عن سير المعارك عن السيطره
انا كنت اسال عن مهاجمه المواكب خلال
عمليات الاجلاء خلال هذه الفتره فتره
الهدنه التي سيتم فيها اجلال اعتاد اجنبيه
دبلوماسيه من العاصمه الخرطوم الى خارجها
ربما الى دول مجاوره او حتى كما حدث في
العمليه النوعيه الامريكيه تضارب البيانات
في استهداف هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه الا
يفتح الباب لعمليات قد يعني تنتج عن
هذه يعني قد قد تصيب احد هذه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه لا يعرف لا يعرف مصدرها طالما
ان الجيش يتهم قوات الدعم السريع والدعم
السريع يتهم الجيش بانه هو من استهدف
البعثه الفرنسي على سبيل المثال
انا كنت بصدد الاجابه على سؤالك بمدخل
محدد وهو ان الجيش الذي اختار ان لا يصيب
المدنيين في الخرطوم وهم كما تعلم اصبحوا
في عدد من المواقع في الخرطوم من خلال
تواجد قوات الدعم السريع وكانت خطه
العسكريه بنيت في الاساس على الانتشار في
الاحياء وهذا الامر بسبب ازعاج كبير للشعب
السوداني اذا كان الجيش لا يريد ان يقمع
لديه القدره كما هو الحال في 17 ولايه بل
اكثر من تلك الموجوده في الولايات في
الخرطوم ولا يستطيع ان يوقف حركه قوات
الدعم السريع اللي توقع الدقه في عدم
اصابه المواطنين السوداني
ين فاخلاق عسكريه رفيعه للغايه لا تتيح له
الهجوم على على البعثات الدبلوماسيه وانتم
عرضتم منذ قليل في شاشتكم المحترمه
من السجناء الذين اطلس
وهم تحدثوا عن الدعم السريع اقتعمت السجن
واطلق الصراحه 7000
في غالبهم او ربما جميعهم لديهم جرائم
تتصل يعني لا تتوقف عند القتل والنهب
والسرقه
وذكره صريحه العباره ان الدعم السريع دخل
للسجن للحصول على الاقتزاع وبعد اطلق
السجناء وكذلك الحال تم في سجن الهدى وانت
تحدثت عن تعرض
الموكب الفرنسي والموكب القطري والاسرى
المصريين واتخاذ المواطنين
لفتح الممرات الانسانيه امتداد المستشفيات
يبيع قضايا
لا لا يجب ان تتبع في مثل هذه الحروب حتى
اجبار السودانين على مغادره منازلهم من
القناصه في الدعم السريع
انا اؤكد لك الجيش السوداني لا يمكن ان
يعتدي على مواطن ولا يمكن ان يعتدي على
بحث دبلوماسيه
من هذا النوع ترتكب عصابات منتسبه ربما
للدعم نحن نتحدث بسرعه عباره الى ضيفك
الاخر صديق فايز النور يتحدث من الخرطوم
كيف للاخ
يسمى معنا ان يصوغ لغيم نقل وتوطين
الديمقراطي عبر فوات البنادق اي ازدواجيه
هذه التي يتحدث بها فاذا النور ما الذي
يريد ان يسوق للشعب السوداني كيف ياتي
بدمقراطيه عبر فوهه البنادق واشلاء
المواطنين وانتشار البارود والغنابل في
المدينه من اي ديمقراطيه يتحدث عنها فايزه
النور يا استاذ دعنا نقول صريحين يعني
وغير
ربما ان الحديث الان عن الديمقراطيه يعني
هو
سابق لاوانه لكنني اريد ان اسال الان عن
عن الاحداث عن خروج هذه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه هل الجيش قادر على تامينها
برايك وخروجها من الخرطوم
من البداهه يا استاذ من البداهه ومن
العلوم ومن الطبيعه السوداني الجيش الان
يسيطر على المجال الجوي السوداني كيف
لطائرات تدخل المجالس قوي السوداني بدون
تنسيق مع الجيش السوداني هذه بداها كيف
الجيش السوداني يمتلك اقوى اسلحه الدفاع
الجوي في السودان في البر هذا هو الشريط
الذي عبرت منه الطائرات التي جاءت لتنقذ
المواطنين او الرعايه الاجاري كيف لا تعبر
الحدود السودانيه والاجواء السودانيه
والدفاعات الارضيه والسودان يمتلك سلع
الطيران هو الان الكف المرجعه لانه يمتلك
سلاح الطيران متقدمه دعنا نكون امينين
ازال الجيش السوداني هو الذي ينشغل هذه
العمليات عمليات الادلاء وانا اؤكد لك ان
الشعب السوداني بطبيعته الفطريه لا يمكن
على الاطلاق ان يعتدي على اجنبي صبغا
عملنا في المنظمات الدوليه
الماينست
ين والامريكان ان الشعب السوداني شعب
مسالم في الغرى والارياف هذه التصرفات لا
تشبه قيم الشعب السوداني ولا تربيته ولا
سلوكه الشعب السوداني الشعب يعني لديه من
القيم والاخلاق ما يكفي لحمه ويحسن كل
الاجانب ويحميهم ويغفر لهم الرعايه
الكامله الذين يتصرفون بمثل هذه التصرفات
لا علاقه لهم بالقيم ولا بالاداب العسكريه
التي تخرج في الكليه الحربيه ولا علاقه
لهم بالنشئه والتوطين للمواطنين
السودانيين في مناطق السودان المختلفه
وجنسيات ولغاتهم شعب لا يمكن ان يختلف
الاشياء نستطيع ان اؤكد لك ان الاجانب في
مامن ما لم
تتعرض لهم بعض القوات المتفلته التي فقدت
القياده والسيطره من قياده التي هي هايمه
على وجوهها في الشوارع في الخرطوم نكون
صريحين ونتحدث بشفافيه ليس هناك اي مواربه
او اخفاء للحقائق لكن قائد قوات الدعم
السريع امس في مقابلته مع العربيه قال
بانه يسيطر على كل افراد وعناصر قوات
الدعم السريع والا افراد منفلتين في
الشارع او عناصر تتحرك بمفردها
ولماذا لم يسيطر عليهم عندما اطلقوا
السجناء في سجن الهدى ثمانيه الاف او سبعه
الاف سجين ولماذا لم يسيطروا الى سيدي ام
درمان والتحاول او اطلقوا بعض الرعايه من
تلك المناطق ولماذا لم يسيطر عليهم عندما
دخلوا بعد البيوت والاسر وخرجوها من
منازلها لكي تسيطر على مواقعهم القناصه
اين هي السيطره في هذه الاشياء هو يقول
بانه يملك القرار باطلاق
السجناء مثلا ما حدث في سجن الهدى دون
اقتحامه او يعني
اي عمليه لاخراج السوداء او السجناء تقوم
بالقوه
من يريد ان يوطن ويرسخ لقيم ديموغرافيه هل
يضرب بالعداله هكذا عرض الحيط ويطلق
السجناء حكمت عليهم محاكم وتمت فيها
مساؤلات قانونيه اي ديمقراطيه واي تسيطره
واي عقل وهي علم يتطلب مثل هذا السلوك حتى
تثبت انك انت رجل محب للشعبك انت
تحب
الاسواق ساعود اليك خالد للحديث عن هذه
النقطه وهي نقطه هامه في هذا التوقيت سيد
خالد ابقى معي ساعود اليك نعود الى
الاوضاع الميدانيه مشاهدينا حيث افاد
مراسل العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات متقطعه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع في الخرطوم
واستمرار حركه النزوح من الخرطوم الى
ولايات سودانيه اخرى من جهه ثانيه افاد
موقع رصد ان السودان يعاني قطاعا شبه كامل
لخدمه الانترنت مع دخول المعارك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها
الثاني وقالت منظمه
ومقرها لندن التي تعنى برصد الوصول الى
شبكه الانترنت في العالم ان بيانات الشبكه
تظهر انهيارا شبه كامل للاتصال بالانترنت
في السودان حيث تبلغ نسبه الاتصال الوطني
حاليا اثنين في المئه مقارنه بالمستويات
العاديه
تهدد ازمه المياه حياه السودانيين بعدما
شهدت البلاد انقطاعا تاما للمياه الصالحه
للشرب اثر استهداف المعارك محطات المياه
في العاصمه نتابع
متى ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء
كنز
من بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع المياه في
السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر مياه عكره
باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره ثم
رجع رجع جنب البير وقع جنب اخيرا يعود
بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني من عطش
اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته يلجاون
اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد تعينهم
لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في المياه
الصالحه للشرب
دي انقطعت تماما المويه
بنكون في شوارع ما بنلقى جردل
شوحوا المياه يضرب العاصمه الخرطومه بعد
معارك بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
استهدفت محطات المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوا في تاريخ السودان غيداء السالم
العربيه عد الى لندن والى الكاتب الصحفي
خالد عيسى مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى اريد
السؤال قبل الانتقال الى الشق الانساني عن
ما حدث في سجن الهدى اطلاق الاف السجناء
الاف المجرمين طبعا من هذا السجن كيف
سينعكس ميدانيا على الازمه السودانيه
في الراهن الحالي
وبالتاكيد مستقبلا
اطلقت عدو مجلس السياده في مبادره انسانيه
وهي كانت خطوه خاطئه بالتاكيد في وقتها
عدد من السجناء في سيدنا جرمان تمت
بمبادره بعض الصحفيين وبعض الناشطين هو
بالاسف ظهرت نتائج تلك الحاله بعد اسابيع
قليله في انتشار وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه
وارتكاب العديد من المخالفات والسريغات
هؤلاء هؤلاء مجرمين تخرجوا من السجون
فما هو المتوقع المتوقع هو سرقها نهب بقتل
تشريد بالتاكيد هذه العمليه ستضر بالمجتمع
السوداني وبامنوا لفترات طويله حتى يعني
بعد استقرار الامور وبالتاكيد الان هناك
عدد من الحالات
للمحال التجاريه وهكذا وجميعها ربما من
هؤلاء المت
سلطين لا توجد حركه لا يوجد محلات تجاريه
لا يوجد فرصه تحقيق الكذب الحلال والرزق
اليومي وبالتالي تصبح
الفصوص السرقه والقتل وتكسير المحاله
التجاريه حتى على اقل تقدير يعني الحصول
على ما يسد الرقم وهذا مفهوم في الصياغه
الظرفه الحالي وبالتاكيد في المستقبل
سيكون لهم اثار بالغه التعقيد ان يتكرر
ذات السيناريو في سجن كوبر
لا استطيع ان احكم بحكم يعني عدم معرفتي
بالضرورات الامنيه المحيطه بالسجن ولكن
حسب ما افهم ان سيدنا ستكون عليه ايضا
تحصينات كبيره بحكم
يعني العلاقه السياسيه بين هذا السجن
والموجودين في داخله وال
وضعنا الى الموقع الذي يقع فيه على مغربه
من المواقع الحيويه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم
اما سيدنا الهدى فهو في خاصي مدينه درمان
من الناحيه الشماليه وهذا يتطلب قدر اكبر
من الوجود العسكري وهذا ربما يكون غير
متاح في الظروف الحاليه
سجن الهدى لم يكن يملك تحصينات مشابهه
لسجن كوبر او على الاقل يعني تحصينات
تتناسب مع مع السجن مع اي سجن
السينات التي تتناسب مع وجود اي سجن
موجودا مما هو متوقع هو قوات خاصه لحمايه
السجون هناك وجود لقوات عسكريه كبيره
بمدرعات ولكن ان يعقل يمكن
ان يضع احتماليه هجوم قوات تدعي انها هي
الدوله وتدعي انها هي التي تريد ان ترسخ
قيام الديمقراطيه وتدعي اما هي المنغز
للشعب السوداني وتدعي ان هي حاميه لمن
الوطن ان تهاجم سجن عسكري اي مدرسه
اكاديميه عسكريه في العالم يمكن ان تفكر
هذا التفكير حتى تضع دبابات ومضادات
لاسلحه ثقيله كما هو كتلك التي تتوفر
وتدعم السريع الحمايه موجوده يا استاذ
ولكن لا يمكن لاي عسكري في اي مكان في
العالم ان يفكر ان هناك
شعارات كالتي يرفعها الان ويهاجم سجن في
عتاه المجرمين
فهم ي
هؤلاء جميع الابناء وطني التعامل معهم
بمساحه متوازيه ولكن الخطا في نظري
الاعمال التي ترتكبها وتدعم السريع لا
تحتاج لاي نوع من الموازنه ولا الخداع
الذي يحدث خطا كبير يجب على اقوات الدعم
السريعه ان تتداركوا باسرع ما تيسر حتى
تحافظ على ما تبقى لها من احترام في عيون
السودانيين الذين يحبون الوطن ويدركون ان
هذه القوات كان لها سهم كبير في حمايه
السودان وارجو ان لا تهدد كل هذه الكذب
التاريخي على الجانب الاخرى الازمه
الانسانيه في السودان تحديدا في الخرطوم
ازمه شح المياه كيف تعلق عليها
انا في تقدير الشخصي ان السودانيون
المهندسين في مجال الكهرباء والمياه على
قدره كافيه لتشغيل هذه المؤسسات الخدميه
الحيويه الضروريه ولكن كما هو حال
المؤسسات الطبيه الان التي ربما تحتاج الى
نوع من الامدادات والى نوع من فتح الممرات
الامنه لكي يصل هؤلاء المنتسبين للمواصفات
الصحيه او المستشفيات الى مغار عمله نفس
الحال ينطبق على المؤسسات الخدميه في
مجالي الكهرباء والمياه يعني يجب ان يتفق
الان السودانيون على فكره منح لون محدد او
اتفاق بين يعني الدعم السريع والجيش على
تحديد هويه اشخاص بالوان مميزه حتى يكونوا
متحركين دون التعرض لاطلاق النار العشوائي
الذي تطلقه بعد الجهات المتفلته ولكن تبقى
المشكله الكبيره هي ان هذه القوات الدعم
السريع ليست لديها علاقه مع سلطتها
الغياديه بحكم ان التواصل بينها وبين
القياده انقطع منذ تدمير
التي تتصل في القياده والسيطره وهذه مشكله
كبيره ولكن انا استطيع ان اؤكد لك ان
الجزئيه حمايه من الطرفين وهذا الامر
يحتاج الى جهه بعض الشيء لكن يعني في في
ظل هذه الظروف هل يمكن
اعاده المياه تحليه المياه وكذلك ايضا حتى
الكهرباء والانقطاعات التي تعاني منها
السودان بالاضافه ايضا حتى الى ضعف الكبير
في خدمات الانترنت
[موسيقى]
يعني حتى اذا استمرت الايام اكثر من ما هو
عليه ستبدا الخدمات في التراجع وهذا بديهي
وعمر طبيعي يصاحب عاده الحروب لا سيما في
المدن
المامول يعني تتوقف هذه الحرب بعد ما تيسر
حتى تبدا الحياه تعود من جديد يعني انا
على تواصل مع عدد من مدن السودان هناك
الخدمات
لم تتاثر كل مدن السودان بهذه الحرب الا
في بقع يعني في مناطق محدوده وتم حسمها في
ساعات الاولى من هذه العمليه لكن الخرطوم
وهي عاصمه كبيره وفيها تعدد كبير والخلاف
الليزي يجري الان هو يعطل الحركه ويعطل
حيويه في هذه المدينه وتقديم الخدمات
بالتاكيد يعني استمرار هذا الصراع سيؤثر
سلبا على الخدمات كهرباء مياه انترنت والى
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن الكاتب الصحفي
خالد اللاعيسر
في تصريحاته للعربيه قبل قليلنا في
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم
السريعه فارس النور طرح انفسهم كبديل
للجيش واكد استعداد الدعم السريع
للاندماجي بالجيش بعد تطهيره من عصابات
سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره ان
الجيش
نحن حتى
يعني احنا ما صارحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
ميحنا دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديلين للجيش
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
فارس النور اكد انها هدفهم الرئيسي انجاز
التحول الديمقراطي لدوله مدنيه
نحن دخلنا هذه المعركه هدفنا الرئيسي
والذي الان اذا المعركه حتجيب بسبب هذا
الهدف هو انه يتم تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
والانسحاب المكون العسكري من العمليه
السياسيه لانجاز التحول الديمقراطي
للطلبوا الطلبه السوداني دي مهمتنا وده
دورنا وده اللي حنمشي فيه وده اللي مضحي
من اجره كما تعمل مستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع فارس النور عن انصراط
مندسسه بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على الدبلوماسيه
على البعثات الدبلوماسيه وتحميل مسؤوليتها
للدعم السريع
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على السيارات التيارات السفاره
الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
كلها
[موسيقى]
تغطيه الى الاحداث في السودان مستمره لكن
نتوقف مع ابرز الاخبار على الساحه الدوليه
احتج نائب وزير الخارجيه الصيني على
تصريحات رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بشان تايوان
وقال انها غير مقبوله على الاطلاق وقال
لسفير السوء لدى بكين ان الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبي لم يشر الى مبدا صين واحدا لكنه
ساوى بين قضيه تايوان وقضيه شبه الجزيره
الكوريه في اشاره منه الى قضيه شبه
الجزيره الكوريه وقضيه تايوان
قال مسؤولون محليون انما لا يقل عن خمسه
صواريخ روسيه اصابت مدينه خاركيف شرق
اوكرانيا والمناطق المحيطه بها حيث كتب
حاكم المنطقه على تطبيق تيليجرام ان
صاروخا اصاب منزلا في احدى القرى جنوب
المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ اخر في اندلاع
حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها والحق بعض
الاضرار في مباني المدنيه اخرى هذا وتطلق
روسيا منذ اشهر طائرات مسيره وصواريخ ضد
مجموعه متنوعه من الاهداف الاوكرانيه في
محاوله لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
دعا وزير وخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
بوريلا القوات البحريه للدول الاعضاء في
التكتل الى القيام بدوريات في مضيق تايوان
وشدد بوريل في مقال لصحيفه
على ضروره ان تكون اوروبا حاضره بشده في
قضيه تايوان التي اعتبرها مهمه على الصعيد
الاقتصادي والتجاري والتكنولوجي
اعلنت وزيره الداخليه الالمانيه ناسي بيزر
توصل الحكومه والنقابات العماليه الى
اتفاق بشان رواتب اكثر من مليونين ونصف
المليون موظف في القطاع العام اوضحت
الوزيره في بيان ان كل عامل سيتلقى ما
مجموعه 3000 يورو على شكل اقساط حتى
فبراير العمل المقبل
للمساعده في التعويض عن التضخم
هذه الساعه مشاهدينا من تغطيتنا للاحداث
في السودان انتهت لكنها لا تزال مستمره
على شاشه العربيه الزميل احمد الهادي
يلقاكم على راسي الساعه في تغطيتنا
المستمره الحيه والمباشره على شاشه
العربيه منذ تسعه ايام وحتى اليوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات